[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi.
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and today I'm
going to show you how you can
take the Google Assistant SDK
and build it into your
existing projects,
from adding smarts
to a toy robot
to having your electronic
potted plant talk back to you.
So what exactly can the Google
Assistant SDK help you with?
With the SDK, your device
can provide the full Google
Assistant experience,
which allows
you to talk to Google to ask
questions and get things done.
With Actions on
Google, you can also
extend the Google Assistant
with your own commands.
For example, you
could build an action
to change the state
of the local device,
such as turning on an LED
light or moving a robot.
In addition, you can use
either the OK Google hot word
or a button that you provide to
start talking with the Google
Assistant.
Finally, you also get to
see the transcribed text
of what the user says.
You can use this
text to implement
additional local
device functionality
based on the conversation.
For example, you could scan for
certain happy or sad keywords
and change the mood
lighting of a device.
The Google Assistant
SDK is designed
to make all this easy
and straightforward,
helping you get from 0 to
prototype very quickly.
For example, you can use
the SDK's Python library
and run it on your own
Raspberry Pi 3 device.
And it also works with
most Linux distributions.
Best of all, the implementation
uses public GRPC bindings
and can be used to generate an
implementation for any language
that you want.
If this sounds like fun, the
best way to get started is
to check out the documentation
at developers.googl
e.com/assistant/sdk.
And also try out some of
the samples we've provided.
There are step-by-step
instructions
on how to get something
working on your device.
And then you can go from there
with building your own ideas.
We also have a developer
community on Google+
specifically for this SDK.
So you can ask questions,
share your ideas with everyone,
and help keep up to date
with the latest news.
We look forward to
seeing what you build
with the Google Assistant SDK.
I'm Wayne Piekarski, and
I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]